nous retrouvons le dr karl weiss
président de l'association des médecins
microbiologiste infectiologue du québec
dr weiss
bonjour à vous merci encore d'être là
c'est très apprécié alors docteur vice
première question vous avez entendu
monsieur trudeau décrété que les
visiteurs étrangers
les voyageurs étrangers ne pourront plus
venir au canada sauf les américains
j'aimerais avoir un commentaire de notre
part là dessus mais je pense que c'est
une bonne mesure c'est la mesure où
beaucoup de gens demandaient depuis très
longtemps alors c'est certainement d'un
très bon pendant la très bonne direction
ça va nous aider à contrôler un petit
peu l'arrivée des cas possibles nouveaux
de coronavirus on s'entend que les
canadiens peuvent bien sûr rentrer au
pays
mais au québec dans l'est du pays c'est
toujours des cas importés qu'on a eu
jusqu'à maintenant à l'extérieur ce soit
des canadiens ou des jantes uniques en
touriste mais c'étaient des chevaux de
troie
ils venaient de plus en plus fréquemment
et le fait de pouvoir laisser en plein
de virus ou voyez combien c'est
difficile de contrôler sainte et on
commence à me sentir aujourd'hui dans
les options qu'on est passé dans une
nouvelle
je dirais dimension de la lutte contre
cette pandémie
dr weiss dans quelle mesure toutes les
mesures extraordinaires annoncé ici au
québec partout au canada vont être
efficace pour freiner la cour parce que
jusqu'ici je vous montrais la coupe
canadien évidemment c'est
impressionnable qu'on est parti de zéro
à 423 cas quand même assez rapidement
est-ce que vous avez espoir qu'on arrive
à aplanir la fameuse courbe lance alors
la tenir à un moment donné et c'est sûr
ça va continuer à monter il faut
comprendre on n'est pas capable de
tester tout le monde on a encore un
petit peu de retard sur les tests des
efforts considérables mais je parle de
l'ensemble du canada tient probablement
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas encore
testé mais qui sont potentiellement
contagieux qui transmettent le virus
alors tout ça mis ensemble fait que et
là on en apporte beaucoup de retours de
jantes en hausse nos moeurs qui
reviennent de floride qui reviennent
d'ailleurs
sont souvent des personnes âgées qui ont
des facteurs médicaux autres et qui
auxquels s'ajoutent potentiellement de
la fièvre lorsqu'ils reviennent et qui
semblait des six encore plus grand à
gérer alors il ya un ensemble de
facteurs fait normal on va avoir encore
beaucoup plus le cas à augmenter et ce
n'est que la pointe de l'iceberg
c'est ça avant d'aller mieux ça va aller
mal en fait on se prépare sur le groupe
harley de 400 milles au québec comme
potentiel de malades
dr weiss je vais commencer avec les
questions du public y en a beaucoup
marie-eve gagnez vous demande je suis
considéré à risque car j'ai voyagé à
l'étranger j'ai des symptômes
je suis en attente pour un test depuis
trois jours est ce normal mais justement
pas justement faudrait livre c'est un
peu normal dans la situation actuelle vu
que la quantité de tests qui a été
demandé à dépasser les capacités du
laboratoire qui fait un travail
remarquable il faut le souligner les
gens ici c'est peut-être en attend plus
longtemps mais le travail qui est fait
par donne au delà de ce qu'ils peuvent
donner mais c'est sûr que là on est en
train de passer des stages les hôpitaux
et comme l'a dit madame à cannes il faut
rapidement les hôpitaux aussi vont
prendre le relais et vont venir soutenir
de l'abattoir son pécule
c'est la clé les tests comme l'a dit
l'om espèce est la clé pour contrer
voilà c'était ce qui était essentiel dès
le début il fallait déjà se préparer
depuis plusieurs semaines parce qu'on
savait que avec les tests on va pouvoir
gérer beaucoup mieux les lits d'hôpitaux
il faut comprendre que dans les hôpitaux
on a beaucoup de gens qui sont en
attente des résultats de tests in
bloquent en partie le fonctionnement du
système hospitalier
une fois que ces tests là vont être
disponibles ça va nous donner une
certaine erin concédèrent pour pouvoir
bouger ces gens-là lit quoi ça va
permettre d'avancer plus rapidement la
gestion des lits très bien madeleine
razoux demande j'ai un rhume et ça
revient beaucoup leur chat jouglar ponge
j'ai un rhume depuis trois semaines pas
de fièvre ni une moue nulle part est il
possible ce soit la coved 19 autrement
dit la différence entre un rhume et le
covan 19 alors
souvent d'abord il faut pas oublier
qu'au québec et dans l'état actuel des
choses on a encore beaucoup de virus
respiratoires tu l'influenza la grippe
circule encore de façon assez importante
on a d'autres virus du rsd
métapneumovirus donc il ya beaucoup de
virus qui circule encore au québec
alors d'abord si ça fait trois semaines
que vous avez des symptômes c'est
probablement pas le commis 19 un autre
chose c'est que pratico-pratique les
symptômes du cabinet fabi tuellement
vous voyez plus la toux et de la fièvre
au moins chez les gens n'est plus malade
les gens qui ont des rumeurs à nador oui
ça pourrait être d'un autre côté trois
semaines ça va un petit peu contre ça
madame benoît vous demande numéro 7 est
ce qu'il est possible de savoir si les
gens qui ont eu le virus au québec sont
guéris au canada sont guéris si oui
sont-ils encore inclus dans nombre de
cas là c'est la lumière au bout du
tunnel c'est qu'on a guéri la pompe
bon je vais plus parler oui voilà
majorité des gens heureusement dans les
hôpitaux mais on voit beaucoup de gens
malades et donc c'est clair que il faut
savoir gérer cet aspect là bien sûr
quand on guérit dans la majorité du
temps et heureusement il ya probablement
des gens pendant le pâtissier qui ont
guéri
donc tout ça mis ensemble on espère
quand même le message
oui vous allez être malade mais on
espère que ça va être quelque chose de
limiter très bien une recommandation a
été émise en europe sas a beaucoup
circulé en fin de semaine je vous
entends ne pas prendre date ville et but
prochaine ça car ça peut aggraver
l'inflexion devons nous suivre cette
recommandation
écoutez son orientation sait pas trop
pour affaire avec vous savez dans ce
virus là ce que les gens doivent
comprendre c'est que des fois on apprend
des choses mais l'évolution de la
maladie nous c'est comprendre autre
chose alors c'est une constatation qui a
été sept en france est-ce que les gens
qui prenaient des anti inflammatoires
non stéroïdiens lescar en parler du
prophète était plus malade et donc
finalement ils sont allés plus mal parce
qu'ils étaient plus malade et c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont pris des
anti-inflammatoires ou est ce que les
anciens
voiron vraiment contribué à leyment
direct par le contexte ce serait
peut-être le cri dans prudence de
prendre l'acétaminophène là où sans
faire de près de deux commerces de
propositions commerciales là c'est la
marque du tylenol
il ya une des clés de tout ça marie
andrée colette vous demande les cas
provient-il tous de contagion à
l'extérieur du pays
est ce qu'il y a des cas de contagion
entre personnes au canada au québec
alors la majorité l'immense majorité il
ya toujours où le lien au voyage est
peut-être plus ténu qu'il était passé
c'est à dire on peut voir des gens qui
ont été en contact avec des gens qui ont
voyagé mais qui eux n'ont pas forcément
voyager donc mais il ya encore si vous
voulez un lien relatifs au vert et que
le voyage mais c'était attendu toute
façon un moment donné ce truc là se
répand dans la communauté et il faut
s'attendre à ça oui c'est bien ville
être clair que si on est testé positif
suzanne robert demande qu' on est malade
combien de temps on a beaucoup entendu
le 14 jours là mais c'est quand les
malades sont là là combien de temps on
va être malade mais ça dépend des gens
mais c'est surtout compter à peu près
une semaine dix jours 14 jours et ça
dépend ce qu'on appelle malades en phase
de récupération un moment donné donc un
moment donné vous allez récupérer parce
que vous allez plus faire de fièvre vous
allez voir c'est mêlant tous des fois ça
peut persister longtemps là où ce genre
de choses là même dans un simple rhume
les gens passent tous et des fois
pendant des semaines qu'un vice merci
c'est très apprécié vos lumières
quotidienne comme ça il y aura d'autres
questions et on se reparlera je rappel
faisait toujours riches
merci beaucoup de nous avons prévu en
soirée